[Música]
el presidente guillermo lasso declaró el
estado de excepción en guayaquil luego
de un ataque con explosivos que dejó 5
muertos y 17 heridos el gobierno lo
calificó como un acto de terrorismo y
ofreció una recompensa de 10.000 dólares
por información
en colombia el alcalde de la ciudad de
cali propone crear una empresa estatal
dedicada al cannabis la idea se enmarca
en la propuesta del presidente gustavo
petro para ampliar la legalización de
esta planta hablamos con el funcionario
familiares de los mineros atrapados en
una mina de carbón en mexico se quejan
de las demoras en las operaciones de
rescate las autoridades continúan
bombeando el agua de los pozos y todavía
hay obstáculos que impiden descender
hasta el fondo
hola bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en france 24 los
saluda andrés meza muñoz empezamos en
ecuador el presidente de guillermo lasso
declaró el estado de excepción en la
ciudad de guayaquil luego del atentado
con explosivos que se produjo la
madrugada de este domingo y que dejó 5
muertos y unos 17 heridos el gobierno lo
calificó como un acto de terrorismo y
una declaración de guerra al estado
además ofreció una recompensa de 10 mil
dólares luís muñoz tiene los detalles
terror en guayaquil los narcos
evolucionan sus métodos disparos y una
fuerte explosión resultado muertos
heridos y desaparecidos también ocho
casas destruidas el presidente guillermo
lasso anunció medidas en twitter he
declarado en estado de excepción a la
ciudad de guayaquil debido a los sucesos
delictivos dados en las últimas horas se
dispondrá de toda la fuerza pública para
restablecer el control de la ciudad no
permitiremos que el crimen organizado
pretenda manejar al país el suceso tuvo
lugar en el barrio del cristo del
consuelo a las dos de la madrugada una
moto lanzó una bolsa con explosivos y
sintió muy fuerte fue yo pensé que era
que estaba temblando en la tierra lo
primero porque o sea la cama se movió un
remezón y esto sí yo cogí amigo lo jale
con angustia el bebé y me iba a salir
corriendo como loca pero me calme ya y
me quedé y ahí dice aunque no queda bien
la medida que había tirado en la calle 8
la policía investiga y busca información
ofrecen 10 mil dólares de recompensa
desde el primer atentado con explosivos
contra civiles
se degrada día a día él se va de mal en
peor
o sea multiplica la situación
guayaquil vive a una ola de violencia
por el control del narcotráfico es el
epicentro de américa latina' para la
exportación de cocaína la tasa de
homicidios por 100.000 habitantes en
ecuador ha pasado de 6 a 14 desde 2018
el reflejo de la situación se ve en las
prisiones donde más de 350 personas han
sido asesinadas en disputas entre bandas
pasamos a colombia jorge iván ospina el
alcalde de cali la tercera ciudad del
país se sumó a la propuesta del
presidente gustavo petro para ampliar la
legalización del cannabis concretamente
el funcionario plantea la creación de
una empresa industrial y comercial que
sea del estado y dedicada a cultivar
producir y comercializar cannabis
previamente hablamos con ospina quien
detalló cómo se llevaría a cabo este
proyecto
digamos que desde la colonia las rentas
para el licor o para el tabaco era
monopolio del estado y hay una vasta
experiencia pública en administrar y
gestionar empresas de licor
creo yo que ahora tenemos una nueva
realidad que es el tema del cannabis
para múltiples usos
tal vez no haya mucho debate para su uso
medicinal y su uso industrial en
producción de artículos telas etcétera
hay un gran debate con respecto al uso
lúdico del cannabis jorge iván ospina
también nos contó cómo encaja esta
propuesta en la legislación colombiana
con respecto al cannabis
bueno la legislación colombiana hoy pro
posibilita el consumo en la producción
de cannabis para uso medicinal hay
certificaciones entregadas por el
gobierno nacional hay empresas privadas
participando en el tema pero digamos que
la reglamentación se han mantenido los
propósitos no alcanzan a arrancar en la
dimensión que se necesita y colombia
todavía no tiene digamos una un manejo
claro en términos de la producción
comercialización mejoramiento de
semillas para la distribución de
cannabis ahí nos hace falta mucho
legislar para que entidades
territoriales como la nuestra de crear
la empresa puedan efectivamente
desarrollar todo un proceso de
distribución y comercialización el 77
por ciento de los suicidios en el mundo
se producen en los países de ingresos
bajos y medios venezuela es uno de ellos
donde este problema de salud pública se
concentra especialmente en el estado de
mérida registrando el doble del promedio
nacional 10 muñoz tiene más detalles
henri de la cruz es bombero entre sus
múltiples funciones hay una que jamás
hubiera deseado hace unas semanas tuvo
que dejar su moto y detener a un joven
que estaba a punto de saltar de un
puente y traté de
salvarlo porque él iba derechito a
tirarse al vacío
y nosotros nos caímos en hacer
henry logró impedir un suicidio pero no
siempre es así el estado de mérida
registra 99 suicidios por cada 100.000
habitantes es el doble de la media de
venezuela
thais beltrán sobrevivió a dos intentos
de suicidio tras el abandono de su
pareja llegó al límite ahora participa
en la ong somos donde trata de ayudar a
personas con pensamientos suicidas
entonces el hecho de que uno tenga esos
pensamientos o tenga esos intentos hace
ver como que la familia se avergüenza de
ti como que es un tema que nadie va a
tocar las personas más propensas al
suicidio son colectivos vulnerables
también influye la situación económica y
la depresión las autoridades locales han
lanzado una campaña de prevención
necesitamos formar a la sociedad en este
tema hacer que las personas dejen de
pensar en esto como un tabú desde el
gobierno regional ofrecen asistencia
especializada y gratuita concienciando
sobre el suicidio y cómo prevenirlo
el objetivo revertir las estadísticas
del departamento con más suicidios de
venezuela y continúan los esfuerzos para
rescatar a los 10 mineros que quedaron
atrapados en una mina de carbón en
mexico el pasado 3 de agosto pero los
familiares de los damnificados denuncian
lentitud entre los rescatistas y falta
de comunicación por parte de las
autoridades
11 días han pasado y los familiares de
los 10 mineros que quedaron atrapados en
una mina en el estado de coahuila siguen
sin tener noticias de sus seres queridos
denuncian que los trabajos de rescate no
han avanzado como esperaban y que las
autoridades han evitado dar respuestas
concretas sobre el estado de la
operación terminan trabajando hemos
seguido como deben de ponerse
salen a comer y durante las dos horas
descansando descansar mucho
ese es el problema grita que tiene la
gente no nos dice no sale nadie a decir
nada
durante la última semana las autoridades
y los equipos de rescate han estado
bombeando agua fuera de la mina para
permitir a los rescatistas entrar en las
cámaras pero durante la madrugada del
domingo ocurrió una inundación que
retrasó el rescate de los trabajadores
en efecto los rescatistas solicitaron
más ayuda para que los expertos puedan
descender a la mina nos ayude más vidas
extranjeras donde sea pero que nos
ayuden que dejen bajar a toda la gente
que
la capacita para esto los mineros
quedaron atrapados en el interior de la
mina de pinabete el pasado 3 de agosto
cuando sus trabajos de excavación
provocaron el derrumbe de la pared de un
túnel y posteriormente la inundación de
tres pozos y seguimos en mexico porque
la ciudad de mexicali en la frontera con
eeuu esconde una historia de emigración
a finales del siglo 19 cientos de barcos
con población china llegaron a
territorio mexicano para intentar cruzar
a estados unidos- muchos al no lograrlo
se quedaron en mexicali samuel salgado
nos cuenta los detalles
5 simbólica estructura de la
arquitectura china se alza en mexicalli
ciudad del norte de méxico a miles de
kilómetros del país asiático el zinc
señala el inicio de la chin ska
centenario barrio chino a quien arturo
villaseñor abre las puertas y revela
secretos de la magia del barrio
cuando su secreto
[Música]
por qué
pero más allá de la gastronomía las
decoraciones chinas y los callejones que
albergan sótanos bajo su superficie la
chinescas esconde una historia de
migración
a finales del siglo 19 en medio de la
decadencia del imperio chino cientos de
barcos provenientes de cantón y hong
kong desembarcaron en las costas del
pacífico mexicano a bordo de ellos
inmigrantes chinos que buscaban mejores
oportunidades económicas en el pujante
eeuu muchos de ellos no pudieron cruzar
la frontera y se instalaron aquí en
mexicalli donde ahora se replican
algunas tradiciones de aquel pueblo
migrante
luego de años de abandono debido a la
falta de recursos económicos la chinesca
vuelve a ser de interés para las
autoridades locales y para empresarios
que ven la oportunidad de atraer a
turistas
hasta que es informativo en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]